the ad pocalypse it's still going strong
[Music]
imagine paying for an advertisement to
be shown but even though no one watches
it you still have to pay for it on TV
you can actually never know if someone
is watching your advert maybe they're
out taking a piss
maybe arguing with their wife eating
being distracted whatever you still have
to pay for the ad to be shown well on
YouTube it doesn't work like that if you
don't watch the entire ad or for at
least 30 seconds you don't have to pay
anything no money is basically lost so
it seems pretty safe to advertise on
YouTube at least it seems pretty great
if you ask me
advertising on YouTube can give you a
wider reach than any TV network could if
your target consumer is 18 to 34 YouTube
has a Hawaiian reach than any TV network
than any cable TV network and according
to a research conducted by Google
maybe a little biased but they found
that in 80% of cases ads that were shown
on YouTube as opposed to TV were 80%
more effective to drive towards a sale
and you know I may be a little biased as
well but I believe that fact because on
YouTube you can target your consumer
much much easier
you got demographics Geographics time of
day retargeting of ads and base of
interest ads we've have shown to be
highly effective user doesn't just know
who your target consumer is they know
what they like what their behavior is
like and you can reach them directly not
not guessing and let's say you want to
buy the product that you see in the
advert what you got to do you got to
walk outside and go to the store
ridiculous you can just click on the act
and buy it they're so simple then
advertising on YouTube seems like the
greatest thing ever I know well wait
there's more on TV ads you got to pay a
certain amount to get your ads shown
alright and it could be
pretty expensive well on YouTube if you
want to pay a dollar to advertise you
pay a dollar that's all you got to do
there's no limit and let's say you want
to pay a million 50 million you can pay
50 million no one's going to stop you
all right why not spend a little extra
while you're at it because if you
advertise on YouTube you're also
supporting independent creators all
across the world you can also get
organic views on YouTube hey what do you
mean with that
well you know those Old Spice
commercials millions and millions of
views you don't turn on the television
hoping that you'll see one you go to
youtube to watch it you're basically
getting people to watch your
advertisement for free whoa
advertising seems amazing why is why
would I possibly never advertise there
but Felix I've heard that it's not safe
to advertise on YouTube there is a
racist videos out there and what if my
ads appear on them YouTube have
extremely strict rules on D monetization
even before this whole ad pocalypse
happened and ask ask any creator you
talk about politics you really will get
to monetize literally I play a game with
the single bit of sexuality in it like
no nudity whatsoever
it gets demonetised it's very sensitive
it's a very strict system that's in
place and like I said even before all
this outbursts and people know that if a
coca-cola ad appears in my video that
doesn't mean that coca-cola is
supporting my views whatever they may be
it's this common sense people know this
already it's just an advert and if you
want to advertise on YouTube you can
reach out to creators directly and
target your ad through them get a video
done together and then run your ads
across their video specifically if you
want a more authentic way of doing
advertisement you can't find it it
doesn't exist we can talk directly we
have an audience that listen to us they
care about what we say and they trust us
if you're scared of your ads showing up
in the wrong
you can see through analytics exactly
where your money is being spent Oh what
what site I don't need the media to tell
me about that that's so strange
it's almost like the whole thing is just
blown out of proportion I could just
look online and see where my ass is
being spent as money is being spent on
how about that is right there in front
of you TV doesn't have that that's very
interesting
and if usually wasn't even more safe
they added even stricter rules and for
your ad money to be spent the creator
has to have more than ten thousand views
on the platform essentially eliminating
anyone to upload anything and have ads
on it because let's say if a news
company wanted to take for some reason
advertisements from other companies and
place them directly on racist content
for whatever reason I can't think of
they can no longer do that I think it's
interesting recently what happened with
Pepsi they pull ads off from YouTube to
avoid controversy and came up with an
advert they they probably spent millions
and millions and millions of dollars on
and it flopped it got a ton of
controversy because it didn't reflect
reality YouTube is painfully honest and
it's reflection of what the audience
really want if you don't like on
something on YouTube you'll know not
only was the advertisement offensive but
it was also on authentic people know
this why because just look at the
dislike bar I know it's a kind of a
stupid metric to bring up but it's
anonymous and it shows that this type of
way of doing advertisement is not
relevant anymore the way media like to
portray things is no longer a reflection
of reality